is this food making you hungry well
don't try to take a bite because these
delicious-looking foods are actually
fake TV shows and movies will try to use
real foods on screen when possible but
there are a number of reasons why food
props might be used instead for example
if ice cream is used they don't want it
to melt between takes or if you need a
lot of food in the background of a shot
companies like independent studio
services and display fake foods offer
pre-made food props that can be ordered
in bulk but oftentimes movies need items
specially made that's when they seek out
a fake food artist like Lisa Friedman
for people who need something specific
that's why they reach out to me I'm an
artist I went to school for art and I
also love to cook and bake there's not a
lot of us out there that do this Brenda
Chapman also makes fake foods in
Oklahoma I just kind of figure it out so
I had no formal training didn't go to
college started this just so I could be
a stay-at-home mom with my kids both
women work out of studios in their homes
they can recreate pretty much anything
much of their day-to-day business is in
restaurant displays and food shows but
prop masters will contact them if they
need food items for movies in the last
20 years I've done almost three million
dollars with him a fake food business
Brenda has had her work featured in a
number of productions for Glee
she made some ice cream for this diner
scene the in their diner scene they
wanted milkshakes and hot fudge sundaes
and banana splits that were new happy
quarter eaten so that they could switch
them out during the that takes she says
you don't always know where your food
will end up like when some of her items
popped up in the muffets when Miss Piggy
eats my doughnuts I didn't realize that
they had bought my doughnuts of course
and sometimes your food doesn't even
make the final cut
Thor action the movie actually bought
like $500 were the donuts and they had a
building that said donut shop or donut
plan they never went inside so I do see
my Donuts is very sad here's a
creamsicle Lisa Friedman mean that was
featured in a scene from Kevin probably
saves the world
the coldest thing they have thank you I
guess
his eye was swollen he got hit in it
well the details may vary based on the
artist the creation process is pretty
standard
we stopped by Lisa Freeman's home in New
York to see how she makes her fake foods
after the order is submitted typically
the customer will send her a real
version of the food they want duplicated
then she will produce a mold out of the
item to get the exact size and shape we
tried it mold it close to the color so
that we're not starting with a blank
white canvas typically fake foods are
made with rubber or foam she pours the
material into the mold and lets it set
foam rises like actual dough so she
needs to prevent it from spilling out
it's like I'm baking a cake right and
I'm baking my bread then she sands the
excess pieces down once the item is dry
it's painted and detailed to look like
real food with my background in painting
I can color it to be as you know as
realistic as it is you just kind of have
to look at things a little differently
and think okay it's not made for this
but it doesn't look like this we do use
a lot of styrofoam's
a lot of just stuff from the local
hardware store you know caulking and
drywall patching and sheetrock mud to
replicate granola and ground beef Lisa
uses crushed cork board cork is kind of
like breaks up like granola so we took
some cork boards and we started breaking
it down sometimes real food is used like
covering actual popcorn cereal or candy
and resin to preserve it
it's often hard to tell the finished
product from the original I don't do
this for the money it's kind of more for
the accolades when my customers right oh
I love it it came out great
and while these items might make your
mouth water they're only a feast for
your eyes
[Music]
you